salut aujourd'hui on est mardi mais je
sais que quand vous regardez la vidéo on
sera lundi et le lundi c'est jour de
blogues
aujourd'hui je vais jouer à landsberg
comedy club au sentier des halles je
vais la bague d'autres maurice pour
tester les sketchs etc vous emmener avec
moi
m
dégueulasse
sélectionne c'est l'image qu'on donne
suisse on parle de foot du beauf ou
d'hatem ben arfa
désolé c'est pas non plus le plus mon
petit tu veux sauf que dans ce cas tu
vois tant dans sa cabine où était posé
une ou deux questions
moi je suppose que tu les connais déjà
c'est moi qui paie cette voie là
c'est vraiment très présent mentalist le
requin s'est déroulée tout répond vite
ok c'est troisième
jeune âge 33 ans maintenant
c'est hyper bien reçu alonso grande
comédie club je peux te dire qu on
picole
pourquoi tu as ça et pourquoi moi j'ai
ça je n'y peux rien apparemment tu y
travailles trop
toronto -
la foire enregistrements sont
aujourd'hui
d'après vous qu'est ce que cet avis
m
c'est
cela veut dire encore l'excusé partie du
goût ouais ça fait combien de temps que
tu fais partie du mouflet deux ans des
anges depuis début août voit tout le
monde est en train de constater qu'on se
marre bien dans les loges ça faisait
longtemps que ce n'était pas vu ton ciel
de plaisir que des vagues d'aliens chain
la mauricie sont drôles tout le temps
soit dans les loges toutes les photos
dans l'âme heureusement dans le bonheur
c'est pas une légende en plus tôt les
gens que tu peux me dire des divers
défis que tu as vu mais rapidement là tu
sais pourquoi eric pas parce qu'ils sont
tous empreints de générer 2 on ne peut
pas faire ça en fait on est assailli des
informations au quotidien on peut bâtir
ont retenu correspond vraiment ce que
vous à partir d'un divine corp a perdu
son fils près tout ça du coup merci
bertrand pour l'avenir je lui demandé à
tous ceux qu'on affronte préférant tête
de lever la main qui revient à dire de
la salle des sports la lumière leur
enclos de montres oui d'accord
oui d'accord yens d'actions pendant
japonais cette action ç'a d'entraînement
s'est jamais rien est ce que tu peux
lever myriam parce que tu peux jeu
tendre le bras l'apprendre vers le haut
comme ça il est inscrit dans les ligues
de ta main tu vas me rejoindre sur scène
voilà merci
c'est d'ailleurs quand même
les mavs escalade vente forcée et
projeter mentalement des images de ban
ki moon a calé prétention je me sens
vraiment tu joues le jeu mentalement
c'est possible ou pas oui projet
imaginons le pire devant moi je prends
une scène du film n'apporte sa quête
dans ta tête si c'est dur de bord des
benjamines est bonne les pompiers
avaient enfin le faire également
on a soutenu que cette banque comme si
on regarde l'exemple cité des images
avec serge areguian d'accord c'est un
intérieur latéral interne on veut comme
une chatte
il prend son film américain 6 un noir et
blanc.c'était anciens d'accord est ce
que tu peux essayer de passer les
acteurs les actrices devant toi demandé
aux représentants de parler je sais pas
c'est pas défoncer connu ça est ce que
tu peux aller au tout début du film que
je vois le match et néry s'affichait
pour moi c'est un titre de film entre
1,6 et ça c'est un film que j'aie safin
de sa peine azam revenir c'est sous la
droite de l'eau d'un bateau
m
10h07 a dormi
et voilà c'est la fin de ce blog
j'espère qu'il vous a plu le blog c'est
tous les lundis sur la chaîne je sais
pas encore ce que je vais bloqué pour la
semaine prochaine deux matches la ligue
le russe comedy club de berin aussi ça
vous dit que je bloque ça vous pouvez me
le dire dans les commentaires si ça vous
plaît de voir ça n'oubliez pas de
laisser aussi également un petit pouce
en l'air ce matin sur facebook je vous
ai posé une question pour la vidéo de
jeudi donc n'hésitez pas à aller sur
facebook pour y répondre comme ça on
fait une vidéo un petit peu ensemble
vous avez compris le principe abonnez
vous n'oubliez pas que c'est une vidéo
par jour pendant un an et rendez vous
demain pour le prochain mentale vlog
ciao